ああ
あれだか耳が待ってんだけどあーあー
ミクきってこうちょっと来いって言ってるからさちょっと痛いじゃないですか
左匹釣れたら三世それに大者名簿はこう割れしてるからそうなんか
キモツこんにちははじめたそうです耳かきが綿棒かで言ったらどっちかというと綿棒を
使っていますね今回はこの耳か次回にあるなら風が好きだなーふぁにゃん弁護に者から
嫌だきゅーぶっくりなんでこんなのが今あるみたいですよ
耳の中に崩さずんだった美味なんだかを傷つけ用綿棒入れると3名のだと傷つくから
このもう吸い取っている
っていうかんこれからこの馬牛に吸い取って耳の中の京都全部吸いとるらしいです皆
笑顔で使ってますね
おめでとうございます僕を名簿を作ってたまに日に刺さっちゃうんでちょっと痛いんで
お皿これはちょっとデータに使ってみましょう
こんな感じです全自担担でこれでますそれでこれでこれであっ
これを耳に打つさしてみるの中のゴミをするで吸い取るらしいですね
とあ
全部なくしちゃった2まずでいっぱいありましたよ河童ラストチャンスだこれでいい
ですよねたぶんこれで日にぶっ挿すとも終っちゃったことを取り入れてみる本当に
入れるよ
うんもうすぐこれだいないジョブかな
吸い込まれている感覚がないですね吸い込まれているという感覚がないしちょっと風の
とかめっちゃ聞こえるな耳の中で台風が起きてる気分です
はい私は思ったこれたして考えをすばらしいですばキューまで吸い取って耳の掃除され
て来ない素晴らしいんですけどもなんて言われたこれで吸い取ってでもなかなかことれ
てる感覚なんだ今これの原理をそのまま利用させていただきますこれの原理を利用して
掃除機の吸引力でスイート面はことすら耳そうじもっと公開的にできるんじゃないかと
思いまして今度でもっと暗いてくる実
理想とするために透析をちょっと改造して耳掃除マシンを作っていこうと思います
なんでこんなかと思ったんだろう
そう思ったときには
すでに
手遅れでした
ちょっと弱いんですよねここはどうだとも掃除機で吸い取っ立ってきたな
叙勲も旋風に漱石で歌っていいんじゃないかと思って
さあはい
ああああああ
ブーバー男女ねこれ
日本語難しいなぁ一筋縄ではいかんぞてきて来た珍しい造りだけ
ん
あれ午後トレ前かぁ
rar
これすごいなぁ
予想以上に強いだこれ耳の端に入る大きさにこれを仕上げればいいわけなんてほんと
こういう感じねこれでアーリオうまいこと囲んでどうぞ吸い込むところが本当に
ストローク話が水後場に入りしますこんな感じでございますこれで掃除低下オンにして
みて
3米入れ今ご覧いただいたようにしっかりも町民ができてるので
俺ちょっと興味3頭としてみようと思いますスイープうわぁ
th
ていたっ
鼓膜が痛いので
間にせない